[Music]
well after more than a week away from
competitive play the golden knights
skating back on the ice at t-mobile
arena tonight this is the start
of a two-game series with the rival la
kings
including a game on super bowl sunday
john treach here now with more on the
high scoring game tonight
that's right you don't realize what you
have until it's gone vegas missed
monster trucking over
weak teams in the west today the golden
knights turned on the ignition
and crushed the kings 50 seconds out of
quarantine the golden knights
ripped the court how about nick hague 22
years old and full of life and
goal scoring ability tonight first goal
of the season second of his career first
period
golden knights bullying the kings at
this point still
max paceretti sets a plate for mark
stone and stone feast
two to nothing and the almighty first
period kept going two nothing well the
kings just need a hug instead they got a
marchessault
goal three to nothing after one five to
the final
vegas improves to 6-1-1 on the season
and will play a rare noon game
on sunday the game will be over by three
plenty of time to talk to your family
before the super bowl starts at 3 30
on channel 8. that is a full sports
sunday thanks john